[Music]
the world is full of very talented
artists that are able to create
unimaginable worlds so of course when we
heard that some artists are turning
cartoon characters into actual people we
just had to put them in a video the
human version of Spongebob Squarepants
is spot-on don't forget to subscribe to
our channel to never miss another video
and hit that thumbs up button if we
showed your favorite character today
we're talking about 10 popular cartoon
characters reimagined as people Kung Fu
Panda
check out the fierce-looking human
version of the beloved master Pope
hanger from the Kung Fu Panda from the
face shape to the clothes this is one of
the best human versions of PO we've seen
the artists behind it is a talented
illustrator from Russia she is known for
drawing reimagined characters do you
agree with her representation of the
Kung Fu Panda to refresh your memory PO
is a playful Kung Fu fan who's inspired
by some of his favorite warriors and
action figures and although he's
passionate he's also incredibly clumsy
the mischievous look with an arched
eyebrows shown on the human version of
PO definitely portrays his playful
nature the cartoon version of po lacks
discipline but surprises everyone with
his impressive kung fu skills it is
exactly what the adult version seems to
be doing - and we think a bald human
version of PO is a completely accurate
representation after all one of much
beloved pose saying is my fist hungers
for justice as his stomach rumbles we're
pretty sure the human version of PO
could also kick the mysterious bud but
now we want to know how the rest of the
Kung Fu Panda characters would look like
the Furious Five Kung Fu Panda
characters ask and you shall receive
here are the other members of the
Furious Five this illustration belongs
to the deviantART user Cora or VAD this
artist did an amazing job capturing the
personalities of Kung Fu Panda
characters and turning them into their
human form meat Viper on the very left
tigress behind her master monkey in
front of him PO in the middle crane on
the right and mantis far right we
absolutely adore the human version of
Viper who looks just as caring and nice
as Viper in the movie and then there's
tigress the one that takes no nonsense
and is one of
fiercest warriors we have ever seen look
at her muscles and speaking of muscles
check out those muscular abs on master
monkey who looks just as mischievious as
he does in the movie crane looks way
cooler and we bet he doesn't take
himself as seriously as the cartoon
version does and then there's mantis the
sarcastic little guy that's willing to
stand up to just about anyone his fierce
pose shows he's exactly like the Mantis
in the movies you better watch out what
do you think does this team look like
what you imagine the human Kung Fu Panda
team to look like Simba and Nala Simba
and Nala are true relationship goals so
there's no wonder you can find many
drawings of how they look like if they
were humans and we approve of all of
them we particularly love this drawing
belonging to the same artist who drew po
from Kung Fu Panda and this version of
Simba and Nala is just as couple goals
as the cartoon what do you think do you
agree with Simba ginger hair and now as
long blonde hair the lifelong best
friends and later loving partners are
among some of the most favourite Disney
characters do you think the human
version of malice still keeps Simba in
check or has there been a switch in
their personalities we love their gentle
relationship and it seems like they are
just a sweep of their cartoon versions
of course you can find many other
versions of human Simba Nala out there
check out this drawing by deviantART
user called forgotten ladies now these
two look fierce and ready to leave their
pride the artist made sure to keep the
drawings in line with the personalities
of both characters Nala even has
piercing teal eyes while Simba's eyes
are strikingly red scar The Lion King
ever wondered how scar from The Lion
King would look like as a human we
believe this is one of the best
transitions out there and it's pretty
accurate long dark hair green eyes bone
piercing through the zere a goatee and
warrior clothing we think this
illustrator totally nailed it scar was
motivated by jealousy and although he
was highly intelligent he chose to use
his powers for evil ever since he was a
young cub scar hated that his father
never spent time with him and he
despised that his older brother got to
be a king we love the calculative look
the human scar has as it perfectly
portrays his expression but at the same
time he's charismatic enough for you to
trust him the bones of his body also
show his intimidating side
and then there's of course the scar he
received in a fight this image belongs
to a deviantART user who goes by the
name of checkup
what do you think did they do a good job
how do you think this scar was moved
would he take a stern in quick walk or
would he take his time and move fast but
in a fluid way almost like a snake
Sponge Bob Squarepants who lives in the
pineapple under the sea
Sponge Bob Squarepants who has now been
transformed into a hilarious human form
that perfectly suits him just like kung
fu panda and Simba Nala this image was
also created by the same talented
russian illustrator the detail of this
drawing is particularly impressive and
the SpongeBob's personality is
accurately embodied in this small child
from the hat to his freckles and his
tooth gap this child looks just as
hilarious as the real Sponge Bob
Squarepants we bet he's quite a handful
and he probably gets in trouble all the
time
but Sponge Bob also has a very sweet and
innocent side to him which is why
turning Sponge Bob into a child would
make sense in the cartoon SpongeBob's
age is never officially revealed but the
creator of the cartoon said he's old
enough to live on his own and still go
to boating school we wonder if he'd
still live in a pineapple under the sea
or would the pineapple also be turned
into something more suitable for humans
who knows you can also find several
other amazing spongebob drawings out
there but we were particularly impressed
with the detail of this one Olaf from
frozen just imagine how much cooler I'll
be in summer who doesn't love the funny
singing snowman that desperately wishes
he could experience summer Olaf is one
of frozen's most popular characters and
we can definitely see why he's very
goofy and giggly but at the same time
he's so innocent you just can't help but
love him is this how Olaf would look
like in summer dressed in white with a
goofy grin on his face
this Olaf who also looks like he's
working in a hospital portrays the exact
same personality we love how the artist
managed to keep the shape of Olaf's
carrot nose and made it human Olaf
originally has three stone buttons his
carrot nose snowball legs
twigs his hair and a buck to the human
Olaf despite having way more here than
just a few twigs is absolutely perfect
and here's more good news if
laughs would have his human shape he
could see what summer actually looks
like and we bet he'd find out what
happens to solid water when it gets warm
what do you think his buddies would
think of him is this the OLAP you've
imagined as a human that's funny
Wow check out this Bugs Bunny this
amazing drawing belongs to a deviantART
user that goes by the name of sashimi
Chan Bugs Bunny is probably one of the
most beloved cartoon characters that
ever existed although he could be goofy
Bugs Bunny was able to face any
challenge he's smart and effortlessly
cool which is exactly what this human
version is portraying
we love his fancy suit white gloves and
the chain belt with a little carrot the
human version of Bugs Bunny comes with
short gray hair and of course he's
holding bunny ears in case he ever needs
to go back to his bunny character hold
up one second look at this detail the
human Bugs Bunny seems to be drinking
from a glass of carrot juice as a
cartoon character Bugs Bunny had many
outfits I was able to cosplay is pretty
much anyone including Scarlett O'Hara is
the human version of Bugs Bunny's still
able to flawlessly break down the gender
binary but the more important question
is is the human Bugs Bunny still
sticking to his famous what's up-dock
line the same artist also drew a human
version of Lola bunny and although she
seems to be into basketball she's
probably still madly in love with buds
Mike Wazowski and Sully of course we
can't forget about her two favorite
monsters and best friends in the
monsters world it's Mike Wazowski and
Sully the human version of Mike and
Sulley were designed by a pixiv user
named Vega Shima and believe it or not
they even managed to capture Mike's one
eye by cleverly giving him stylish side
bangs Sulley on the other hand is still
shown as big and muscular we love his
blue hair and of course he had to keep
the horns
these two monsters University students
play the part what do you think although
we have to say the human version of Mike
Wazowski
doesn't look like he's having a good
time we wonder if his legs and arms are
still just as long as his cartoon
character although there's a lot of
debate as to when Mike and Sulley
initially met who's best friends for
life have been through they
then some of our favorite Mike and Sully
moments include their very first morning
as roommates at monsters University and
we can't forget about taking care of the
cute boo these two are definitely BFF
gold and don't forget they scare because
they care Lightning McQueen and who
could forget about lightning McQueen he
had a mission to win but learn far more
important things about life with his
famous saying cacao lightning McQueen
slowly learned about the importance of
friendship as his story developed the
self-absorbed lightning McQueen was
reimagined as a human and we are
absolutely in love with this
illustration because of lightning
McQueen's personality we think it's fair
to say the human version of the cartoon
car would actually be a child Lightning
McQueen has blue eyes which are
beautifully featured in the cartoon
version his red paint has been turned
into red hair
matching eyebrows and red racing
clothing and it really suits him do you
think the human version of Lightning
McQueen is just as arrogant as the
cartoon character or does he have
sweeter moments we wonder what the car
of the human Lightning McQueen looks
like this Lightning McQueen was
illustrated by a deviantART user called
Chacko but you can find many other
equally as impressive human versions of
the famous race car on the web do you
think Lightning McQueen looks better as
an adult donkey from Shrek this charming
donkey was also designed by the very
talented Russian artist we've mentioned
in this video what do you think the
cartoon version of the donkey is always
hyperactive and fast talking not paying
much attention to other people this is
probably why many get annoyed by his
presence he's played by Eddie Murphy who
managed to turn the donkey into one of
the most beloved cartoon characters what
do you think about the human version of
the donkey could he live up to the same
expectations believe it or not there
were a few theories out there that claim
the donkey from Shrek was initially
human remember Pinocchio and the boys
that ended up turning into donkeys at
Pleasure Island well a reddit user had a
theory that one of those boys became the
donkey you see in Shrek there's more to
this theory since Pinocchio is actually
featured in Shrek movies and all other
characters come from a specific berry
tale everyone except for the donkey if
the donkey was ever human we could see
him looking like this guy his eyes his
hair and his a okay look are just
spot-on
do you have a favorite cartoon character
let us know in the comments below make
sure you never miss a video by clicking
the subscribe button if you're looking
for more fun videos check out 10 amazing
houses inspired by your favorite cartoon
[Music]